they make it their business to mind your
business a binghamton new york high
school may ban hoodies which is somehow
supposed to thwart bullies new jersey
just banned trash-talking at high school
sporting events there's a lot of stuff
like those i ran games that shouldn't be
sudden i think we're there dan is good
who could be against fighting bullying
students coaches and spectators may not
make harassing statements related to
gender race ethnicity disability sexual
orientation or religion and since
harassment is a fuzzy term don't be
surprised if some who support the policy
today get busted by it tomorrow in fact
the state attorney general may actually
investigate trash-talking students but
hey here's your nanny new mexico state
Rep mary helen garcia she sponsored an
anti-bullying bill which would
criminalize speech motivated by an
actual or perceived personal
characteristic including race sex sexual
orientation physical attribute familial
status gender identity religion and
socioeconomic status garcia touts the
bill is a way to protect the children of
course but UCLA's Eugene Bullock notes
her bill also applies to adults in
situations far removed from schools say
you've been criticizing some politician
over some stupid bill then your words
cause substantial emotional distress
blammo you could be guilty of
misdemeanor bowling punishable by up to
a year in prison I better call Saul
other states are thinking about
criminalizing bullying and you can bet
it's just the beginning and that's why I
fight for you Albuquerque critical soul
follow nanny the month on twitter submit
your nanny nominees and click here to
watch another episode